can you explain why outlining matters to
all the screenwriters who
are set against it yeah i mean
you don't want to outline such a degree
that you have no juice left for the
script you know it's not
it's not
like building a concrete wall around
yourself that you can't break out of
it's basically to give you the bones of
structure
so you know where your story is going
now in television outlining is much more
important because if you're under the
gun if they're going to be shooting in
three weeks or two weeks or tomorrow
you can't go off into left field you
have so that's when outline really needs
to be nailed down um in features
let's see what what this really speaks
to is you need to you need to understand
how structure works you know because
structure i early in my career i
struggled a lot with structure and then
there was one period one summer where i
was writing i think all the episodes of
a series for cbs
and um i was writing so much and so
quickly all of a sudden it just clicked
in it was like it went right into the
groove and suddenly structure was simple
for me it was just like built it was
like the bones of a house and the bigger
the story the bigger the house but it's
like the framework that holds it all
together and i understood that and
then it became just second nature it was
very funny when i when michael reeves
and i were were uh outlining the uh the
sulu story the star trek story that we
we did with george takei
we were both old hands michael was a
writer who got me into television at one
point we're outlining the steps and
jotting it down and then about
two-thirds of the way through we just
looked at each other and michael said
you got this right and i said yeah and
then so we didn't outline the rest of it
because we both knew where it went and
then we just wrote it
and but again you have to be a really
old hand to know how to do that stuff
but um
but outlines are great because then you
know well rod used to say rod certainly
you say
that if he knew the ending he could
write a script but if but he said i've
got so many stories where it's a
beginning in the middle and and no end
and he said i can't write those because
i don't know where they go i don't know
how they resolve
and so
outlining rigorously outlining means you
know the beginning the middle and the
end
and uh because you do not want to get
lost in the middle you know and uh or at
the beginning or anywhere
um
because a story
has to satisfy the viewer it has to come
to an end where you go okay well that
was worth my time
and uh and so outlining is very
important it's not i've you know again
if you come up with a better idea while
you're writing
okay if but you have to know that it is
a better idea you can't think oh well
that didn't pay off if it doesn't work
don't do it it's better to follow an
outline that works rather than
experiment
but um
but the more you write the stronger you
get at this stuff you know and um you
just learn you learn your craft and
craft is structure craft is outlining
because um you know
that's just how it works you know it's i
you know it's like i
i write short outlines i don't i don't i
would never write like a 30 or 40 page
outline
but like the most i would do for an
outline would be maybe
seven pages for an hour script um and
with novels
i
i'll jot notes i don't rigorously
outline for novels but i know the
structure i know where the story goes
and i know who does what um
but but there are writers who don't
outline who are still very very good and
succeed
but if you're just starting out i think
outlining is a really important tool i
would urge everyone to utilize it
but but at the end of the day
it's getting to the end of the story
and however you got there if it works it
doesn't really matter how you got there
outlines are just a tool
how would you teach story structure
to someone who needs help i would say
watch movies
that
you feel have a satisfactory ending
and break write down the write down the
scenes write down what happens write
down how the characters move through it
and what the story does and see why that
satisfies
why that works you know years ago i was
hired to do a pilot where one of the
characters was a gangster the sort of a
bad guy at the beginning but then he
helps these two kids and he turns out to
be a good guy and i thought well how how
did they do that trick how did like how
do you do a trick where you like
somebody even though they're a bad guy
at the beginning
and so i watched casablanca and i saw
that everything bogart says is cynical
but everything he does
is moral is ethical and his actions are
speaking louder than his words it was a
very simple trick and a very subtle one
but it worked like gangbusters it was
terrific and so that once i knew to do
that
that told me where i could go
and so you you know there's thousands of
tv shows and movies
don't don't try and invent stuff from
whole cloth
study structures that worked a structure
is like a machine it's like you know um
you don't i don't i always say don't
steal plots but study structure
um because
there's stuff that works and stuff that
doesn't work and the more you deviate
from standard structure the better the
writing has to be so for instance
quentin tarantino can use very unusual
structures but the writing has to really
be solid um
and
so that's just the way the way that
works
how do you write a scene
uh
you try
to have
every scene
have an emotional point
okay
uh you you try to avoid scenes that are
just exposition that's a trap that
people fall into where everyone's
talking just to explain twists in terms
of the story and they're boring scenes
come from character who's who needs what
who wants what who's longing for what
who's hiding what they're really feeling
who's not seeing
what's going on in their heart or in
their head you find the juice of the
scene usually
it's conflict
but not always
you find
something
i mean usually the way it works with an
audience is
the structure is familiar the details of
the story are fresh
so in other words
like if you go to a certain movie you
know okay this is most likely going to
have a happy ending okay but what the
characters say how they get there that's
where you can surprise an audience and
that's where you can engage them um and
so so it might be a sort a story
from your life or someone you know or
something you read or you know any
number of things i mean everything i
write
is a synthesis a combination
of everything and anything um
for instance i knew i wanted to do a
scene in space command that was in
spanish because one of our actors was
was from venezuela and he's very
charming and very very good
victor man so and so when i did the
bonus episode during the pandemic
i said okay i'm going to write a scene
where he's calling his estranged father
to invite him to his wedding
and
and so i wrote the scene in english
and i originally wrote the role of the
father to be guaranteed del toro i
reached out to guillermo and he wasn't
available at that point for various
personal reasons but
but guillermo had had certain elements
from his childhood that actually wove
into that
that scene and
and it was about the son introducing his
fiancee to the father and trying to get
the father to come to mars in that case
to attend the wedding and ultimately
they want the father to move in with
them and it's about
a father's disappointment in his son's
choices and then finally coming to
accept who his son is and see the
commonality between the two of them and
it's a lovely scene and i was really
glad to do it in spanish because i love
the idea of having different languages
in space command for instance mira
furlin and the actress who play her
daughter speak cerebral croatian
uh in when they talk to each other
and uh
but it's a great scene with the father
and the son and the fiance because you
stop
realizing it's in spanish you're so
engaged in the people and reading the
subtitles and so and i had victor
translated into spanish and every now
and then he'd say well it can't be this
exact thing but this will make sense uh
culturally and i said sure fine great
and uh
but i really love that scene because
there's an emotional truth in it
and uh you know so that's that's great
every now and then i'll write a scene
that's just for the gosh g whiz you know
rocket ship taking off or you know
something like that you know battle on
titan or whatever it's very funny
because we were shooting the battle on
titan where these synthetic humans
they're soldiers they're gunning down
these these freedom fighters who are
human and uh one of the extras didn't
show up so i said well i'll put on a
spacesuit i said but you have to you
have to disintegrate me
so i'm in this space when i get hit by a
laser blast and disintegrate with a
scream and it was great fun great fun
yeah bourbon was great at that too what
is it sonata
the the piano player or daughter they
come she's right and then or no no sorry
the piano player mother and then the yes
the the social worker daughter
and and you know it it's you don't need
subtitles to
you know the
tension and the emotion well now we have
thanks to netflix we know that foreign
tv shows can be successful here and the
people will read subtitles and that's
fabulous i'm i'm i'm
so glad of that i well i don't mind me
reading subtitles i absolutely love
foreign films but yeah it helps to read
so yeah it does yeah this comes in handy
and not just ramona cleary books yeah
nothing against them yeah there you go i
like those um
we've heard that and you said this the
other day on your livestream solicitors
we've heard that you say you don't come
up with storylines unless there's a
chance to utilize them
why is that well i might come up with an
idea but the ones that i really dig in
on and write the script um i'm i'm
writing that to shoot it i'm writing it
to make it i'm not i'm not
you know writing it's not an exercise i
never write just for like the i was
gonna say the fun of it i do write for
the fun of it but i don't write
something that's just gonna be in a
drawer that's that's purposeless um
and and and also my heroes when i was a
kid like rod sterling like ray bradbury
they wrote books and tv shows and movies
they could do all three and so i've
always throughout my career written
books tv is my main form tv is my main
art form and my art form of choice but
i've always written books i've always
you know written screenplays as well and
so
uh
and the books were you know i'm really
proud of the books i've done you know
and the twilight zone companion the book
with guillermo green lighting yourself
the magic time trilogy of novels they've
all i'm really glad i got to do them
they were uh
well worth doing
well what if someone says well i don't
i'm not there yet i don't have anyone to
to pitch to or i haven't assembled my
team or we can crowdfund and make this
um
what's your advice to that i mean so
they
should they still be writing just to
utilize them not just to sit in a drawer
you have to learn your your craft you
know you have to know how to tell a
story and you need to get feedback so
that you know if something works or
doesn't work but on the other hand if
you're shooting
you learn very quickly when you're
shooting
if something works because if the actors
can't deliver it or you know i i really
encourage people to
shoot what they've written at least to
see how it works when actors are saying
it i mean you you get a wealth of
knowledge from making it because the
script again is this and it's is such a
quiet object you know whereas if if you
make a short or a feature that can start
getting attention that can start get and
and if it doesn't work
you say oh those characters don't sound
realistic i have to work harder on my
dialogue or or um whoa this this scene
was really boring there was really
nothing happening there you know it's
things will become incredibly clear when
you shoot them and that's again where
television is such a great learning
ground because when everything you write
gets made you very quickly learn what an
actor can say and what they can't and uh
and you know you you it's a very fast
learning curve and i'm very grateful for
that
and
but
i would say to anyone
be bold don't be you know i was gonna
say don't be afraid you can be afraid
but
there's a there's a saying that i have
in my wallet which is the bolder i am
the better things go
and that's so true
you know if you if you fall on your face
you'll get up again you know i people
say well life is like a river and it
takes you where you're meant to go i say
i say to people if you fell in a real
river you wouldn't say that you'd swim
like hell for the shore you know it's
like
you know don't don't just let let things
carry you along figure out what you want
and and but really go for it you know
it's like failure is not a terrible
thing they don't take you off to
writer's jail you know it's they
if you fail get better it's a process
and and
and also by the way
uh you know sometimes what you
write some people will like it some
people won't but if they really like it
if you polarize people where some people
really love it and some people really
hate it that's not bad i mean look at
the work of david lynch you know you
don't have to please everyone you just
have to please someone and the first
person you have to please is yourself
and the way you please yourself is by
saying i got that right that came out
well that was that was great
and um
you know so so
the lovely thing is that it used to be
that you had to come here to hollywood
to make dreams come true and now you can
make them come true anywhere if you're
in east mckeesport pennsylvania or or
kuala lumpur you can still we've all got
phones we've all got video cameras we've
all got the internet it's
make use of what's at hand you're in the
21st century for god's sake you know you
thank god
but
don't waste the opportunity you could
make it you could make a short film this
week you know don't wait
don't wait act ray bradbury had a
wonderful sign over his typewriter that
i now have over my computer that says
don't think
act
and that's so true it's what it actually
is don't think do
and it's like yeah right on yes
absolutely
what was the most polarizing david lynch
work
while at heart doom probably
okay
well no but blue velvet i mean i mean
his i mean one of my favorite david
lynch races uh elaine and i went to see
mulholland
and at the end of that it was a
mulholland drive it's whichever one he
directed muhammad driver i think and
at the end of the movie
you know the screen goes to black and
there's that moment
where everyone in the audience is just
sitting in the darkness before the house
lights come up and someone yelled out
what the [ __ ] was that
and so but i understood what the story
was so in the lobby i started telling i
was surrounded by a crowd of people from
the from the audience telling them what
the movie had been about what it was
because they had totally lost they had
no comprehension and then they said okay
now we get it but
but again it's fine because the thing
about david lynch is he's following his
aesthetic purpose he is telling stories
he wants to tell that only he can tell
great you know great